I would um I'm a two-time cancer
survivor you are yes sir what kind of
cancer ovarian and cervical oh my God
I'm 42 years old and had it way young
where'd you grow up
um I was born in a little small town
called Alpine Texas
um like Southwest Texas
between
Del Rio and Fort Stockton
Theory I mean Sanderson is you have to
go to Alpine if you live in Sanderson
you have to go to Alpine or Fort
Stockton to have your baby there's no
doctors small town very small town one
stop light but it doesn't stop it just
blinks yellow
um everybody knows everybody
what was your family like
well
my mom's family
or my heart my grandparents they were my
they are
rest in peace Mike I just lost my dad
two years ago but sorry I called my
grandpa my dad he was my daddy he was my
whole world
um he was a great man he was on the
railroad for many years
um they got in a horrible car accident
and which caused him to not be able to
work anymore due to like medications
seizure medications and stuff but
because of that accident they want a
settlement of a couple million
and back in the early 90s you know that
was a lot of money my grandfather
of course went crazy with the money and
invested wrong
um he did build an RV park there he had
an auto parts store he made his own
transmission fluids my grandfather was
like this weird scientist
he blew up we made bombs and like that's
why he didn't have any hearing on him
um but he did do one thing awesome with
the many he uh he still owns all the uh
mineral rights to a ranch he bought out
there
so my grandmother still collects you
know from that but
my mom
my mom is uh
she's a strong woman
but she was more a friend
to me
her husband died
when I was 11.
and then my mom just
lost herself you know so I became mom
to my siblings
my dad was a he worked in the oil field
good old white boy
redneck YouTube a real father
they're drinking you know
tool pushing in the oil fields you know
and
he was
he was not
okay let's just say this
he um he thought by just paying child
support to my mom that was you know that
was his way of being present in our
lives but
um
my mom has always been the kind to be
like even if she's married five times
yeah so you know I always swear I
wouldn't be like her
because
I didn't have
I didn't have a childhood you know I was
a mother raising her kids because she
was always too worried about the next
husband
who else is going to take care of me you
know that type of [__] chasing the money
I I get it that you know she to this day
will not admit you know her wrongs and
all that but it's okay you can't you
can't force nobody
but you know due to just having has you
know different households and households
and then my dad picking us up for
vacations and dropping us off with my
drunk ass
grandfather who was the sheriff of the
town
you know
things happen to kids
things happen and uh
what'd you go through and parents don't
want to take a responsibility for those
things because Lord forbid they look
like a bad parent you know what happened
to you
um I was molested by my grandfather on
my dad's side your dad's dad
um sure our body has an amazing way of
suppressing things to help us not
suffer the rest you know for it helps us
forget about very traumatic things when
when you don't say anything at all as a
child I
I wasn't afraid first I've always had a
spirit you know I'm a Sagittarius so
I've always had a free spirit I've never
ever really been afraid of anything but
I just knew that it wasn't right
and I didn't say anything to my parents
until I was 13.
by this time my mom was on husband
I don't know three four
um I started having nightmares about it
and I told my mom
and uh she couldn't say was
well I I thought something was was
always happening to you I just didn't
you know
I thought you were just having bad
dreams because you would you know cry at
night and the man that's gonna get me in
I said how could you not do anything
about it you know and when I told my
father
you know he he's always had um
something terribly uh
against me and and I've never been the
I've always been the pushed out when the
the
different one you know
um
he said nobody in my family would ever
do anything like that to you
you're just a [__] crackhead [__]
and you just want attention
so if your mom and dad don't protect you
and don't believe you
I mean where else do you turn to you
know or
well by this time I'm living in El Paso
Texas
the border is right there
um I started smoking a lot of weed
um and that led to cocaine powder
cocaine like very early at 8 14.
um I went across the border with a
friend of mine her her mom and well her
and her family they're all from from
Juarez
I went over for to go watch a soccer
game
and um
that night
I was raped by her brother
at 14 years old
they gave me the
um a date rape drug in my drink because
we went to a drive-through and they
handed me this big blue drink you know
and I thought I was so badass you know
like hey I'm you know grown up and I got
this cute boy here and mind you he
wasn't even a boy he was 23 years old
and I vaguely remember coming in and out
of it I was
I remember screaming and crying and
pushing him off of me
I remember him putting his hand over my
mouth you know shut up and he was
telling me in Spanish and then the next
thing I remember I'm in a shower and
they're just washing me off and they're
laughing at me
and I'm believing they're just laughing
at me
and the next day
I begged her mom just take me home
please just take me home
and so we crossed over and they brought
me home and
and I just stayed in the shower for
hours
and I never told anyone
I never told my mom I never told a soul
and I remember I I ended up pregnant
14.
and I and I have an amazing relationship
with God you know but back then I didn't
know
but he's he's funny and and he does
things
for his you know for our protection and
we don't even know who he is but I had a
miscarriage
and it sounds strange but I thank him
for that
so at 14
here I am I I didn't get to share my
story about how I lost my virginity with
my friends you know
I just had to make one up and
it was just always a
subject that that
kept me
hostage and prisoner for many years
um from that time on I did any and every
kind of drug you could think of in
excess
to the point of
alcohol poisoning every other weekend
cocaine was
was my Escape that was my main drug as
long as I stayed High I didn't have to
feel
I didn't have to remember you know
because the minute I was sober just
overtook me so my heart that was kind of
like the first callous over my heart and
and
um now I couldn't you know turn to my
dad and I definitely couldn't turn to my
mom because
they don't believe anything I tell them
because I'm always gone they're always
looking for me I I skipped school all
the time
um but I looked for my dad in every man
that came my way
he was the first man that I loved and
the first one that broke my heart
and it's so hard um being an adolescent
and just wanting to be heard you know
we I acted out so much just for
attention
the wrong attention I guess but just
someone to believe me
me and my mom's relationship was just
I mean I was
I was so angry with her I would end up
drinking on the weekends coming home the
cops would bring me home I'd be in the
bars and you know on this side not in
Juarez but over here and
I would hit my mother like I would
I wouldn't fight with her
and she just thought I was
I don't know what's wrong with you I
don't know what's wrong with this child
and they so her and my father put me in
a
a behavioral home I guess so they didn't
have to
as long as they could sweep it under the
rug
that's what they did
no problems ever got solved in my family
you know as long as their names didn't
get tainted and and they had the money
for it and they could push it to the
side it wasn't their problem
so I learned that a very very young age
that I am my own problem I have to have
to take care of me
foreign
they didn't want to understand addiction
because it they thought that that made
them bad parents and Lord forbid they
look back to anyone you know it's so
pathetic you know
um
so
I
we like my mom ended up leaving him that
guy and
we moved
well when we were with him we were in a
little town outside of El Paso called
Anthony then we went back to El Paso
and my mom had a bunch of Roommates in a
big old house and she started taking me
to the bars with her
because I mean
I was beautiful and I could win bar tabs
and contests and they could drink for
free you know
little did she ever
think you know that there was
way older men around me
she allowed me to date a 37 year old at
15.
you know
and I didn't even I didn't I didn't care
because I didn't
know who I was I didn't
I didn't want to know well it was
because I had no when those things
happen to you you just
you question yourself and your whole
existence and
like what the [__] did I ever do to
deserve
everything
foreign
like I was being punished
but the other hand I felt like I can't
even
I can't even act like
I can't even feel sorry for myself
because
it's all my fault
because I choose to get high and I
choose to sleep around and I'm just a
crackhead [__] that's what my own
father called me
me and my mom we fought I mean for years
back and forth back and forth until I
was about 16 and I was in high school I
was going to graduate as a junior
I missed a lot but when I was there I
did really good
um
at this point I was like so skinny
because I was so strung out on cocaine
and when I didn't do cocaine I had I was
on those mini thin pills I just felt
that I had to look perfect and it had to
be perfect
I couldn't make a mistake
because I just wanted to be accepted for
my parents
but
and I never you know happened and
besides my my dad was so racist
and Prejudiced and he tried to force
that down my throat you know
and I hated him for that
to this day I've never ever been with a
white man
just because my father tried to shove
ignorance and hate down my throat I've
never seen color I see people and I love
people I mean that's
that's ultimately like you know down the
road I I know now what my purpose is in
like you know although those all of
these really horrible awful things had
to happen
in order for me to
to know why and and
um so for many years I I um I blamed I
blamed my parents for everything you
know I sat on the pity pot for many
years
um at 16 years old I moved to Odessa
Texas with a cousin of mine
and she was three years older than me
and she had her own little company she
sold roses in all of the bars at night
so right up my alley you know what I
mean
um so I started helping her do that and
boy you know
I'm I met my
my husband
well he's my ex-husband now but
of of nine years
um he was one of the biggest drug
dealers in Odessa Texas
we had Unlimited Supply of cocaine and
you name it he had it I'm 17 at this
point okay and I mean who doesn't
I have
all the drugs that I can ever want all
the money at 17. all the flashy cars
I thought I had it made you know so I'm
up on this
pedestal like you know I'm [__]
untouchable
[__] you and [__] everybody you know
because I can do this so I I
started I started
I started you know becoming so
consumed with
myself like my looks I used every bit of
what I had to get what I wanted
and not even cared or thought about the
cost or the price of it you know
um six months after I met David I found
out I was pregnant with my first child
Marissa
I quit doing all drugs my whole
pregnancy I I didn't do any drugs
um I had my baby nine months later and
then I get a phone call and there's
another woman
saying that she just had David's baby as
well
and never mind okay so
two and a half years later I have my
other my first son and then another two
years later I have my other son but in
between those he had kids
you know lovely relationship it was full
of abuse
mental emotional
so much physical
still didn't know who I was I was just
allowing
abuse because that's what
I was worth that's it that's what I
deserved
but I was a damn good wife and mom
me and David stayed together
about nine years
eight nine years around there when I was
eight months pregnant with my last child
he beat the living [__] out of me
and this is I used to pray to God you
know give me the strength to leave this
man
and it never happened I was just I
became who he wanted me to be because I
was so young
you know and he just I just became his
identity and
and his wife and his
he would rape me to have sex with him
because he was so I was so disgusted by
him and the way he just had kids with
other women and then he just didn't love
me like and once again let down you know
that was the second biggest
callous over my heart
um I never imagined my husband would
ever cheat on me you know because
he did you know he was
the first you know the years were okay
but
after so long you know I lost my husband
to drugs and I don't mean physically but
he never used you know he just sold and
then when he lost his mother he started
getting high and we lost everything
but he was hiding everything from me and
beating me up at the you know when I
would catch on to it it was just
horrible it was horrible my kids were
you know so traumatized by
so I get away from him and go to Austin
Texas with my mom and this is in about
2004.
and mind you I've been with David eight
years and never cheated on the man never
looked at any other man
um but I had to start working now
because he never allowed me to work
well okay I start working at a
convenience store and of course there's
thousands of men that come in and you
know I'm starting to get all this
attention
and um
I'm like hell why not I'm single now
I'll go on a date or two you know but
that turned into going out every night
every weekend getting drunk
um alcohol was my friend for a very long
time
and um any drug at that point you know
but mainly cocaine still
um
I I met this this man
named Joe
um when I was living outside of Austin
in a little town called Haro
and Joe had plenty of money
and loved me
and
never in my life had I ever
thought that Earth
I never thought that just taking money
from him you know in exchange for my
time was prostitution I never looked at
it that way
but it was easy money and
I had three kids and I was by myself
and I started hanging out with Joe a lot
more and I I had never been introduced
to
um crack cocaine
but I went over to Joe's and he was
acting real strange you know one day
and he didn't want to let me in and I
said let me in this [__] house like
let me in you know what the hell are you
doing
so he let me in and I went into the back
room and he had a whole bunch of crack
on the bed
and I seen how
euphoric it seemed when he would get
high and I was like let me let me try it
he said no
I said if you don't let me [__] try
it I'll never come over here again you
will not get no more parts of me nothing
I use that as power you know over man
and like
it didn't make me feel good but I got
what I wanted you know I was this time
it's always been the Christy show you
know it's always been about me and and
uh
so in 2005 I started smoking crack
little by little
turned into
a lot turned into all day every day
never going home riding with him back
and forth to go pick up crack you know
never would he let me out of the car but
I noticed the places that he was going
to you know and he and I'd never asked
him where he was getting the money from
you know but I knew it was crooked and I
know he was finally like I found out he
was involved in like fraud and some
checks and stuff but he never forgot to
to give me mine even if Joe would call
me from deep in Austin and he'd be like
come meet me at the Motel 6 but don't
get mad because I got a couple
prostitutes in here right I don't give a
[__] you know just give me my money
well Joe got arrested and then I still
had a drug habit
so
the little town that he would go pick up
in I paid very good attention to the
places you know he would go to
and I was no I knew that just knew those
streets there were waiting for me
those men
that town
that was like a sheep amongst wolves out
there
so Joe's in jail but I have a lot of
money you know so I go to this one guy's
house and I tell him who I am and he's
like oh yeah yeah I know who you are and
from that from that point on it went on
for
foreign
ERS five good years in a whole run of
crack cocaine and every bit of
disgusting
lifestyle that it entails
um
I learned the game in the streets very
quickly
I learned that I
had to make sure that I did for me
nobody else
can ex I mean I I couldn't let
I was never going to let a man control
my drug habit and my money
I was on the [__] mission to to just
kill myself pretty much you know
I really didn't care my mom took my kids
and that was my the end of my life I
thought
I stayed in that town three and a half
four years
I prostituted every day
I had a very very expensive habit
because I was able to
I was I was very
um
what's the word
everybody wanted
that girl Christy where's that girl
Christy you know where's that white girl
Christy I was
um
and I and I I just knew what to do and I
and I broke a whole lot of bank accounts
and and a whole lot of hearts and and I
just didn't give I didn't care about
anything at this point because
how could you when you're so [__]
high all the time
I had so many instances where I
shouldn't even be here you know
men choking me out beating me up I
started robbing them before they could
even have sex with me because at this
point I'm like [__] you I'm gonna [__]
you before you try to [__] me you know
because
I used to get high to to feel good and
have fun and it got to the point where
when I'm getting high stay the [__] away
from me don't touch me leave me the hell
alone you know I went through so many
years of this and you know
ah
one day
I almost took a man's life
for my addiction
and I couldn't stop I could not stop
choking that poor man
everything that any man had ever done to
me everything it just came over me and I
could not let go
foreign
and I finally got the man to let go of
his wallet
and I left
him in the middle of the street in his
truck
I'm just this is so sick of me like I
was choking the man in the middle of the
day and
waving cars around me they didn't even
know what I was doing I was parked in
the middle of the street
it's insane
once the man let go I I just heard him
gasping and I didn't give a [__] I
grabbed the money and I was I had blood
all over me because he was an elderly
man
and you know elderly people's skin is
just so fragile you know and I just I
had no
I just didn't I didn't give a [__] I did
not care about who I hurt in the middle
of my you know destruction out there
I gathered up the money and I took off
running down the excuse me like down the
alley and I jumped over the neighbor's
fence and I dipped off into the trap
house
and uh
another friend of mine another
prostitute that stayed in there with me
and she said no you didn't
no you didn't no you didn't like let's
get you cleaned up you know what
I said I did I told y'all I was gonna
get that [__] one day you know
well lo and behold you know the devil
never sleeps
and it just so happens that there's a
man in the back room with two big
cookies of crack and I've got all this
money
so I pay them to shut up you know
I'm off to the races I am going again
you know going going going and then
it was never enough
I had but I was afraid I was afraid that
you know that this man was gonna go to
the police
and you know that man did go to the
police and he lied
he said it was a black woman who did it
to him
and I left town I left town I went to a
whole other town I went to Round Rock
Texas
and in Round Rock Texas I go into a
house like this friend of a friend let
me stay there
all these people in there they're
smoking methamphetamine I've never
smoked methamphetamine at this point and
I'm frustrated as [__] because I won't
crack
and methane [__] and I don't want to do
it because see that's a trashy white
people drug
go figure you know I was sick in the
head like [__] what are you
you know you're white stupid but at that
point you know I was raised so Hispanic
like I've never
I've never fit in even with my family
you know
um
something came over me though at this
point I mean throughout all these years
old mind you it was not
it was horrible awful
so many
abuse and just so many men and so much
even women
I was I was whatever I needed to be
at the time for whoever
just to get high over a substance so
[__] small you know it defeated me
but at that time when I went
um to stay with these other people you
know these two guys they had a house
full of strippers in and out and here I
am just like there's no crack here and
I'm about to go back to Taylor like I
so I went out when I one night no no no
rewind I was in the bathroom cleaning
one day because they were all gone
and I just felt something just like come
over me
and I fell on the bathroom floor and I
just laid there
and that's one thing I'll never forget
how it felt what it looked like how it
smelled like
I felt something you just pushed me to
my knees
and I was never like a religious person
or anything but I knew I know there was
a God but I just didn't ever pay no
attention to him you know how could you
when you're batting for the devil you
know
but I just simply came over me and I
just said you know God if you are who
you say you are show me or just take me
because I'm tired of [__] existing
foreign
I don't want to be anybody's problem no
more I don't want to hurt people I don't
want to hurt nobody for me I don't care
for anybody you know just
if I'm around my kids I guess I'm just
hurting them that's so my family you
know says I was a
in all the times that I was that I that
me honestly that I did some [__] up
[__] though
they could never run out to let my
parents did to me
and I still stand on that today
I have an amazing relationship with my
three kids
because it was my addiction
I never let them feel that it was
because of them you know that's just
what it was it was mine did you raise
them yeah
um
my aunt had my dog my daughter because
see I had gotten cleaned up there you
know like I was like when I asked God to
show me who he was boy did he I mean
like he took
I was
I didn't know what to do because that
night I went out
I jumped in a car with three guys
because I just wanted to go make some
money
little did I know they were planning on
raping me
and it was just like how many more is it
gonna take
how many more men have to you don't even
have a soul no more to give you know
foreign
but
I was led to a bar and that I used to go
to all the time
when I before drugs
well hard drugs because to me
crack was the hard drug but powder
cocaine wasn't in a segment sick way of
thinking you know
um
God orchestrated the whole thing you
know and and I ended up meeting up with
a friend that had been in prison that
was a good friend of mine that
ultimately led me to his uncle's house
who happened to be the founder of na24
in Austin Texas
and there was a little
program in the back room called project
Helping Hands and there was only six
beds
and you could live there and get
yourself clean and sober but you had to
attend two or three meetings a day and
you had you know you had rules in curfew
well because I went from one extreme to
the next I went from
wanting to stay completely high and just
to kill myself too
I was on fire inside for something
better than that something greater than
the life I was letting kill me
well
I found out what it was you know I I was
on fire to know my God you know and then
and God placed this amazing person in my
life and he just so happened to be a
recovering heroin addict for many years
you know and uh
he I I I stayed obedient like I wanted
to know the a different life you know
so I went to church with him and I got
baptized and I did all the holy
religious stuff you know but on the
download
the devil came real quick and I was
still getting high
but I was using him because he gave me a
home but see I was I went back to I was
so [__] hypocritical like I had two
faces
going to church with Roman all the time
you know but the minute he would get
upset or angry with me
I just throw my body at him which was so
wrong of me
but through all of this I've always
struggled with addiction
always
it took me to prison
I used I used prison as a as a as a
blessing you know
um
I thought I did
I got out in 20.
there's so much more you know in between
but it's all pretty much the same you
know on the streets getting [__] up
you know doing
we need to come to LA
here we go
I've been here a year
um
so I got out of prison in 2011.
I went back to my home in 2014 and
stayed there until 2000
14. the little bitty Town Sanderson
which I hadn't been there in almost 20
years you know but my mom was there and
she had my boys and my daughter was
living in Virginia with my aunt
so I got out while gung-ho like okay I'm
gonna stay obedient I'm not gonna get hi
I'm not gonna drink I'm not good I'm
gonna be a mother you know
the first night home
I was drunk
sloppy drug
disgusted
with myself
so once again like all of that [__] just
piled back on me
I was like you see you dumb [__] you
can't even [__] State you know
you can't
you can't ever you can't even stay
obedient to anything like
I drink and drink and drink
then I started snorting cocaine again
and this town is so so so small of
course everybody knows your business
before you do
I was tired of it you know my kids my
kids were crying you know I got my
daughter back you know I got my boys of
course and my mom moved off because I
was already fighting with her again you
know fighting with my brother and his
pregnant girlfriend beat her up she was
pregnant beat her up just because I was
drunk you know
so many of these nights I had I had
managed to push every single person
in my life away from me
again
in a matter of months
but as long as I didn't do drugs I was
good you know as long as I didn't
do drugs
I wasn't an alcoholic I just like to
drink there's nothing to do in the town
every excuse in the book you know is it
whatever takes the Shine off of me you
know I'm gonna appoint everybody else's
[__] out to them you're a drunk but I'm
not you know I got in fights I just I
was
I mean and then okay so I got in a
relationship finally
a serious one
and I was tired of being there with no
family
so I called it my dad my biological
father he had moved to by Abilene Texas
Dad hey you got that empty house at the
RV park can I me and the kids come I
want to be by my sister I want to be
around the kids my nieces I I need
family
well he you know bought me a brand new
car my dad came down and he was like I'm
so proud of you like you're doing really
well
um I know your car broke down but he
brought me a brand new car in 2013 he
bought me a 2014 Ford Escape
me and the kids packed up at my new
boyfriend and we moved up there
so all this time I'm in a relationship
with that guy I'm not doing any drugs
but I'm drinking a lot and
violence was always present with me
I wasn't very violent person
I put my hands on so many people in my
foreign
well
we weren't together there very long and
he ended up leaving of course and then
now here I am
heartbroken and
alone again and I start
meeting all these people
I hadn't smoked any crack
since
um 2000
10.
right away as I found the crack
neighborhood in Abilene and then all the
people
and they so quickly became my family
again because the streets were my family
that embraced me that's what I thought
because I [__] the blood people I'll
dare them how dare them love me they
don't love me you know they don't care
because if they cared they wouldn't have
ever allowed me to go this far you know
it was always about poor poor [__] me
you know
then you know I got real with myself you
know this world didn't owe me [__]
they didn't
I I you know I gotta grasp you know I
got it together I dibbled and dabbled in
the crack for a minute
but I met somebody and he was amazing
he was the perfect man at the wrong time
but he encouraged me and he built me up
and he said I I don't see the outside of
you I I see past it I see the hurts I
see all of that [__] that nobody wants
to deal with I see that in you
get off the dope and mind you he was a
dope dealer
and he never would tell me no ever never
gave me dope at all
he said you're beautiful you're a
beautiful ass woman get your act
together and I did
for two years
and then
during my crack days way back you know
in Austin I had met a man
in Bartlett Texas
Billy Carter
and that man opened his heart and his
home to me at that time
and he loved me when I wasn't lovable
and he loved me when I couldn't love
myself
and he taught me how to love myself
again and he became my best friend
of 12 Years
there was nothing in this world that Mr
Carter would not do for me
I never imagined having a
60-something-year-old best friend you
know but he was my strength my wisdom my
whole world I I talked to him it was in
a day we didn't talk
well um
he got sick
and I would find a way to go down there
every weekend after work to go make sure
I was there for him
while he was sick just like he did for
me
and I lost him
very unexpectedly
I never knew what grief was like
I um
I lost everything losing Billy
I went into the deepest depression I've
ever been in in my life
I didn't get off the floor for like a
whole week
I didn't go to work
my kids moved out of my house and moved
it next door to my sister
grief crippled me
I started smoking a lot of Meth
and I stayed
very stuck in that grief
and I started selling a lot of Meth
just I was go go go go going you know
just so I didn't have to think
of him my family turned on me they [__]
on me just because they didn't know him
they weren't there for me they didn't
check on me they didn't all they didn't
give two shits if I was in that house
dead or alive
my kids would come in every day
that would stay gone because it's just
being there
hurt
being there was not good for me at all
me alone is not I'm not good alone
well
I met somebody
um well I'm still currently with right
at that time
he he
um
17 years younger than me
but he was living in Texas and um the
first day I met him I sold him heroine
long story short
um
me and him developed
an awful heroin addiction together
I feel horrible because you know he's so
much younger than me and I made him
stick that needle in my arm
every day all day
we used till I lost everything my dad
took my house away
my kids still weren't with me I just
kept spiraling you know
worse and worse and worse but see I
would hide it
I would shoot up in my breasts instead
of in my arms so they you know but hello
they're coming over and there's orange
tabs everywhere tops and you know my
kids aren't stupid
but I I lied to them all the time it's
not I'm not getting high heels you know
I don't do that
but mind you I'm like deteriorating I'm
getting bumped in and
me and this man had the most amazing
connection
relationship he was so much younger than
me but you know what he loved me more
than any man I ever have been with
treated me
like a queen
it was my whole
he is still my whole world but
I felt like I failed him because
it I I just started doing it just so he
wouldn't
go out behind my back and do it you know
because I didn't Lord forbid something
happened to him because everybody I love
leaves me you know
then dies on me and
from there we are
so we ended up homeless in the streets
of Abilene Texas
we um lived in the car we lived in the
motel rooms and then
um
I told him he needs to go visit his mom
and said you need to go away from me
well you're gonna die we gotta separate
go visit your mom so I sent him to
Mexico
I stayed back in Texas and I just
continued to sell drugs and
but I had gotten clean off the heroin
I went and dipped off somewhere for five
days and I got clean went cold turkey
and I told him look and you can do it
look what I did for us little did I even
think like he was he even ready to you
know get clean I just thought that I
could do it he would see that I'm strong
you know
well
did I know the feds are watching my best
friend and me so I have to get the hell
out of Texas
I call him come get me
he drives 18 hours
to Texas picks me up but he's been lying
to me this whole time saying that he was
clean
that he wasn't doing heroin anymore and
I'm not a dumb woman I know my man
so I get there
and I'm just so like I felt so betrayed
you know and I felt like why the [__]
would you lie to me dude like
why didn't you just leave me over there
if you're just gonna lie I don't want us
to die like I I love you
well oh of course I didn't start
shooting up again but
um I started smoking fentanyl pills
the blue pills the m30s
well we had oh boy you know we were
collecting unemployment getting four
thousand dollars a month between both of
us and we stayed in Mexico for a long
time
but then the horrible awful happened
oh
I get a cigarette
sure right
um
thank you
um we stayed there long enough that we
had met some people down there
you know eventually became our connects
to our drugs to our drug habit
um
he was dipping and dabbling you know
with the heroine but I was just doing
the blue pills you know
I was disgusted you know look I mean I
was a beautiful model at one point you
know and I got check marks for life now
um
but my dude he is a real real attitude
and I got you know to the point where
like when he would run out of money and
and drugs his whole attitude changes and
he
he gets like dope fiendish and he's like
digging in trash cans and looking in the
house for stuff and I begged him like
stop doing this [__] like it's so
[__] embarrassing stop
and he ends up not giving a [__] what I
said and he takes off
remind you where Mexicali Mexico
and he leaves me at this house
never again did I think it
40 years old that
I would be getting over this again I was
raped
a
three days
it's been a year
I was held in a room for three days
they lied to me they told me he was dead
they said everything possible
they
but I believe we're gonna trade a human
trafficking me
um
I was taken up to a ranch and it
then they would take me back in town in
this little room and I didn't eat or
drink anything for three days
they were trying to give me these red
pills in Mexico they call them pingas
it's like a equivalent to like a Xanax
or a Valium over here
I checked every single one of them
they videoed every single part of
[Music]
you see like noises like that I can't do
it still
foreign
because I just remember so many like
four wheelers and big loud trucks and
guns and
I didn't know if I was gonna live or not
but
you know
thank God that
I am by far a dumb human
and then I speak fluent Spanish and
they left me with this man named psycho
and his little like over there in Mexico
they're called cuadras like the blocks
and like the little neighborhoods
this guy had his house burned down but
he still had like a makeshift type
bed or whatever he had in that shitty
room
he was drinking
and he told me to give him a beer and I
put all of those pills in his beer
and I prayed like hell that he would
make him pass out
and I was so [__] terrified
I just thought what the [__] am I gonna
do where's
where's Freddy
is he really dead are they lying to me
well I got away
and when I got away I ran so hard
I ran so hard to a grocery store
and of course in Mexico you know the
police they they won't do [__] for you
unless you have money
they said oh we can just we'll pay you a
taxi and take you to the light
you can go to the United States and see
what they can do for you
they don't give a [__] you know
that my my phone I mean everything that
I own they stole my car everything I
owned was was gone at this point
so they take me over to the line
on the other side of Mexicali
and I get up to the light and I thought
you know what no
I came here with him and I'm gonna
[__] leave here with him
I don't care what it takes I'm gonna
find him and I'm gonna leave with him
and God
if he does not love me I don't know
I ran into a taxi driver that spoke
English really well and I asked him if I
could use his phone to like
Facebook
and I logged onto my Facebook and there
was Freddie I mean he had been trying to
find me too
and he told me where he was staying in
he was staying at the hotel that was
five minutes away behind me
if that's not God I don't know what it
is because that's like looking for a
needle in a haystack
did I go to his door so desperate
how am I gonna tell my dude what
happened to me
but if he left me too you know
foreign
he's not there the room wasn't in his
name
it was in this one guy's name that had
been helping him look for me
they wouldn't let me in the hotel and
mind you he had just crossed over into
Calexico and I just had missed him
I didn't even know
so later on that evening you know we we
get back together
foreign
but of course nothing's free nothing's
done for free and you know that man
wanted me to start working for them over
there
sent me in a vehicle to get it
registered over here in L.A and I told
him I said I'm not going back
I don't care what happens I'm not going
back
and you can't [__] make me and if you
want to go back go back but I'm not
going back
you have no idea what I've just been
through
so you know we didn't go back and we
ended up going back to Texas because my
son graduated high school but
um
my my dude kind of [__] on me too he
turned his back on me and he wasn't
there for me
he said he didn't know how to deal with
that
what the [__] I don't just like I just
prepared for it you know
so that's really been a um it's been a
our relationship is really [__] up
still
but we're still together
um but I started shooting up heroin
again
you came to LA
not yet
I go to Houston
and I died
I did fentanyl didn't know it
died
didn't have nowhere else to [__] go
we came to LA
and we're still using together
I'm not shooting up heroinette and put a
needle in my arm in 12 months
but I smoke fentanyl every day
I've saved 22 people
foreign
and for me I'm I I just want happiness
for him I've lived my life
he's 25 he deserves
to have a life you know he deserves to
get married and have kids and everything
I can't give him
I love him more than he would ever know
but
you know
there's no amount of love in this world
that will ever make an addict quit until
they're ready
so females if you think that your man is
gonna love you
and and they're doing heroin or any
opiate or any drug get prepared to
always be second
and share your life with that because
if they're not going to change for you
I'm getting better though I'm gonna I'm
close to getting housing and I'm gonna
get myself cleaned up
if the Lord permits
all right Christy thank you so much for
sharing your story
yeah you're welcome maybe L.A will be
better to you
it's not L.A it's me
because anywhere you go you can find it
if you want it